-Performing the title track to
their upcoming new album,
"This is Why,"
give it up for Paramore!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ If you have an opinion ♪
♪ Maybe you should shove it ♪
♪ Or maybe you could scream it ♪
♪ Might be best to keep it
to yourself ♪
♪ To yourself ♪
♪ This is why ♪
♪ I don't leave the house ♪
♪ You say the coast is clear ♪
♪ But you won't catch me out ♪
♪ Oh, why? ♪
♪ This is why ♪
♪ Better have conviction ♪
♪ 'Cause we want
crimes of passion ♪
♪ Survival of the fittest ♪
♪ You're either with us
or you can keep it ♪
♪ To yourself ♪
♪ To yourself,
yourself, yourself ♪
♪ To yourself ♪
♪ This is why ♪
♪ I don't leave the house ♪
♪ You say the coast is clear ♪
♪ But you won't catch me out ♪
♪ Oh, why? ♪
♪ This is why ♪
♪ I don't leave the house ♪
♪ You say the coast is clear ♪
♪ But you won't catch me out ♪
♪ Oh, why? ♪
♪ This is why ♪
♪♪
♪ One step beyond your door ♪
♪ It might as well
have been a free fall ♪
♪ One step beyond your door ♪
♪ Falling down an endless hall ♪
♪ Ha ha ♪
♪ One step beyond your door ♪
♪ It might as well have been
a free fall ♪
♪ One step beyond your door ♪
♪ And I'm floating like
a cannonball ♪
-♪ This is why ♪
♪ I don't leave the house ♪
-♪ You say the coast is clear ♪
♪ But you won't catch me out ♪
♪ Oh, why? ♪
♪ This is why ♪
♪ I don't leave the house ♪
♪ You say the coast is clear ♪
♪ But, oh, no,
you won't catch me out ♪
♪ Oh, why? ♪
♪ This is why ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh!